Before we dive into the session material,
let's talk a bit about storing
or persisting data in Android.
First of all, why do we bother
to persist things at all?
This is the era of the connected cloud.
Why don't we always fetch from there?
It's really nice to not start the app
and see, Loading, or, even worse,
like this, a blank screen.
The faster people can use an app,
the more it will be used.
Obviously, if one has to select Refresh
to get it to display anything,
that would be particularly bad.
Another reason to persist our data,
is that using any radio is detrimental
to the battery life of the device,
especially the cellular radio.
Many users aren't on meter data plans
or may be roaming
when they want to use your app.
All those unnecessary
data fetches can add up.
There are still lots of places
that don't have
a network connection available.
One of the prime advantages
of having a mobile app is
being resistant to bad
or non-existent network conditions.
After all, you never know where the user
will want to use your app.
As you might expect, Android stores
your persistent data in the file system.
These files can be stored
in internal storage
that is private to your app.
They can also be stored in shared
or external storage.
On older Android devices,
this shared storage
was actually on an external memory card.
Today, most Android devices
only emulate this card
so that there is the shared external
storage apps need available on the device.
Some Android devices
have emulated shared storage
and secondary external storage.
Android 4.4 Kit Kat added an API
to allow developers to access
this secondary external storage.
We're going to focus
on internal storage in this class.
Check the Instructor Notes to learn more
about Android storage locations.
As I mentioned before,
Android persists data
into the file system.
It does provide two functional layers
on top of the file system in the form
of shared preferences and SQLite.
The Shared Preferences class
provides a general framework
that allows you to save
and retrieve persistent key value pairs
of primitive data types, such as booleans,
floats, ints, longs and strings.
Shared Preferences is used
by the Android preference activity
to store our settings data
such as the location.
Why store things in a SQLite database?
After all, Android supports
both RAW files and Shared Preferences.
For the same reason that it's inefficient
to find things if you throw your clothes
in a pile on the floor.
Storing things in an SQLite database
helps you organize and find data easily,
thanks to the power
of indexing in tables.
An SQLite database looks something like
this fragment from our weather database.
Note that not all fields are represented.
We can perform queries using SQL
against this database,
such as the SELECT statement here,
which returns the weather
on the specified date,
similar to what we'll want to do
for the DetailView.
We can use a slightly more complex query
to return a range of dates
which is similar to what we do
on the main forecast ListView.